certainly view a lot of job disruption
because what's gonna happen is row us
will be able to do everything better
than us looking back at 2017 chatbots
were the next big thing they were
supposed to eliminate millions of call
center jobs replace lawyers and prevent
end-users from ever having to fill out
an HTML form again now it's 2019 and
we're well past the peak of the hype
cycle and I would say chatbots largely
failed to live up to their expectations
but something to keep in mind is that we
always overestimate the change that will
occur in the next two years and
underestimate the change that will occur
in the next ten
I think chat bots are currently sitting
somewhere in the trough of
disillusionment
but conversational experiences can be
very effective when tailored to a
specific business need and in today's
video you'll learn how to build a chat
bot from scratch using dialogue flow
nodejs and cloud functions if you're new
you're like and subscribe and you can
find the full source code on fire ship
IO what we're building today is a simple
chat bot that can collect information
from a user and then save that
information permanently in a back-end
database the natural language processing
technology or artificial intelligence if
you will is powered by dialogue flow
which is a tool for building virtual
agents that can intelligently respond to
user input whether it be voice or text
after the agent has collected the
information it needs it can pass that
information off to a back-end cloud
function and that function can do
whatever it wants to fulfill the request
on the backend which might be something
like sending an email processing a
payment or updating a database for
example when you build a chat bot with
dialogue flow you can automatically
integrate it with a bunch of different
platforms like Facebook messenger slack
and you can now even connect it directly
to a phone line but today we're going to
directly interact with the dialogue flow
API with a node back-end let's go ahead
and take a look at the full architecture
that we'll cover in today's video on the
left here we have our front-end
application which is where the user
interacts with the bot in this demo use
angular for the front-end UI but feel
free to replace it with the front-end
framework of your choice because all
that front-end application needs to do
is make API calls to our gateway cloud
function this function essentially
serves as a proxy to make secure calls
to the dialogue flow API so the user
will enter their message in the
front-end application which will then
pass off to the cloud function with an
HTTP call will then pass that message to
the bot which will give us a response
that we can send back down to the client
now the thing to keep in mind here is
that a conversation will take place over
multiple steps
but at some point the conversation will
finish and the users intention will be
fulfilled when that happens dialog flow
will send a web hook to a separate cloud
function this function can be used to
handle additional work on the backend
and dynamically compute the bots
response so that's how things work from
a high level at this point you'll want
to have a fire based project and then
head over to the dialog flow console the
first thing we'll do on the dialog flow
console is create a new agent an agent
represents an individual chat bot and a
chat bot is really just a tool that
takes user input like text or speech and
translates it into structured data that
you can use in your app I like to think
of dialogue flow as a virtual call
center and the agent is a customer
service representative that's been
trained to solve a variety of different
problems when the user first received
some input it needs to determine the
users intention or the problem that
they're trying to solve for this demo
we'll create a new intent that the user
can trigger to update their user profile
information we'll give it a name of
update profile and then you'll see a
bunch of different options here so let's
go through and talk about each one of
them individually first we have context
which is a little more advanced and
we're not going to cover it in this
video but basically it's a mechanism for
passing data from one intent to another
then the next option you'll see is
events which is optional but it's a way
to trigger this intent without having
the user do it manually and this is
useful in our case because we might have
a user onboarding process and the users
not going to know which intent to
trigger so this gives us a way to kick
off a conversation programmatically in
our code and from there we have our
training phrases these are uh turan
SACEUR short phrases from the user that
would trigger this intent that machine
learning algorithm is going to use
natural language processing to figure
out which phrases are similar to the
ones that you add here the more data you
can add the better but we'll just add a
couple of short phrases here for now
then dialogue flow will try to capture
any phrases that are similar or that
convey the same intent that you've
listed here after that we have action
and parameters when naming an action
it's generally a good practice to use
your domain name in Reverse followed by
the name of your intent similar to a
bundle ID for a mobile application now
when a user triggers an intent there's
likely multiple pieces of data that you
need to collect in order to be able to
successfully solve the problem and
that's where parameters come in you can
set up optional and required parameters
that dialogue flow will try to collect
from the user
we're going to collect the users display
name which will give a parameter name of
name and then you have the entity option
which represents the type of data that
you're trying to collect and this allows
dialog flow to automatically validate
the data that's being collected and you
can also create your own custom entity
for whatever custom data that you're
trying to collect and you can also see
here that we set up a prompt which is
what the agent will ask the user when
trying to collect this data now after
all the data has been collected there
are two ways to fulfill the intent if
you don't have any additional work to do
on the backend you can simply define a
response in the dialog flow console but
in a lot of cases you want to update
something in a database or maybe make an
API call to a third party so for that
you'll need to use a web hook and that
will allow you to write custom code on
your back-end server to format the
response dynamically and handle anything
else that the user is trying to do from
there we can go ahead and save the
intent and then we'll head over to the
integrations tab there's a whole bunch
of different built in integrations like
Facebook messenger slack Twitter Twilio
and many others and there's even a new
one called dialogue phone gateway that
allows you to connect your chat bot with
a phone number and you'll also see one
called web demo that lets you use your
chat bot in a browser but it doesn't
allow you to customize the UI in any way
and that's because we need a back-end
like no js' and a cloud function to
interact with the chat bot so that's
what we're going to take care of next
the first thing i'll do is initialize
cloud functions selecting javascript is
the language from there we can see the
end of the functions directory and for
this first function we'll want to
install a dialogue flow which is the
dialogue flow api client and also korres
because we'll be making requests from
our front-end application now when it
comes to fulfillment there's a separate
library specifically for that called
dialogue flow fulfillment and you'll
also want to install actions on google
if using it and you'll find the command
to install all these with npm from the
full lesson page the first function that
we'll build is a secure gateway that
allows the front-end application to
communicate with dialogue flow on the
backend and we'll import korres which
will allow us to make requests from a
front-end app in the browser but in
order to work with dialogue flow in a
cloud function we need to bring in an
actual service account this is really
easy to do we simply go to the firebase
console and go to the settings tab then
service account and click the button to
generate a new private key this will
give you a JSON file with your actual
private API key which you can download
into
functions directory you'll just want to
make sure to keep this file secure
because it contains your private API
keys so make sure to add it to your get
ignore if you're using a public get repo
we'll go ahead and import the service
account and then we'll initialize
firebase admin using those credentials
and then we'll import the session client
from dialog flow from there we'll set up
an HTTP cloud function called dialog
float gateway and then immediately wrap
the request response with cores and
again that's there simply to allow
requests to be made from a browser
dialog flow is going to be looking for
two things the query input contains the
data that the user is trying to save the
bot which will be in the form of text or
audio in the session ID is a unique ID
that will generate on the client that
allows the bot to determine the passed
messages that were sent in this
conversation from there we'll go ahead
and initialize the session client with
the service account and then we can
reference the actual session by calling
session path with our firebase project
ID and the session ID and then the next
thing we'll do is get an actual response
from our chat bot which we do by calling
detect intent with the session and in
the query input which again will contain
the text or audio that the user is
saying to the bottom this will provide
us with an array of responses but we're
really only interested in the first one
and the query result contains a bunch of
information but most importantly it has
the text that we want to display to the
user on the front end so we'll go ahead
and send that as the response from this
function now we'll go ahead and set this
up in an angular app in just a minute
but let's start by looking at how this
works with just a regular HTTP call you
can go ahead and serve the functions
locally and then pull up your favorite
HTTP client to make the request what
you'll notice is we have a session ID
which is usually unique per user so you
might use a user ID or something like
that and then the query input is the
actual message sent by the user in which
case you're required to provide the
actual string text and the language code
so if the user says update my profile to
the bot the bots going to respond by
trying to collect those parameters that
we set up in dialogue flow so you can
see here that it's asking what is your
preferred name so if we send another
request with our preferred name it will
move on to the next parameter it needs
to collect which is the favorite color
so we'll ask what is your favorite color
and if we go ahead and respond with the
favorite color that will fulfill the
intent so it's going to trigger our
fulfillment webhook which we have
to find yet and respond with whatever
dynamically generated text that is
provided by that function in other words
we've reached the end of the
conversation so if we try to send the
color blue again it's going to respond
with sorry what was that
because saying the color blue no longer
makes sense within the context of the
conversation now let's head back over to
our functions code and we'll set up a
separate cloud function here for the web
hook this is also an HTTP function but
there is no need to wrap it in cores
because we're not calling it directly
from the front-end app and then we'll
initialize an instance of the web hook
client using the request and response
now it's important to point out that
this cloud function will be called for
all intentions that are to be fulfilled
by web hooks for your chat bot in the
default sample code you'll notice a
couple of functions here called welcome
and fallback currently these functions
will never be called because you'll
notice that on the dialog flow console
we don't have web hook fulfilment
enabled for these intents but if we were
to enable those then the bot would use
these functions instead of whatever you
specify in the dialogue flow console
when it comes to our custom intent we
want to set up a function here that will
update the backend database which is
firestore with the new information that
the user passed to the bot we can easily
handle that in a cloud function because
we already have access to the admin
database so we can simply perform a
write with the parameters that were
passed in on this request and once that
back-end work is done then we'll simply
add a message to the agent and that's
what the user will see as the response
from the bot now because this cloud
function is handling multiple intents we
need to map them into an object that can
be called based on the intent name the
default code uses a JavaScript map for
that so we'll continue to follow the
same pattern and simply add our
functions as properties on the map with
the corresponding intent name at this
point you can go ahead and deploy the
functions by running in firebase deploy
only functions and you should now have a
fully functional chat bot that can do
more than just respond to messages but
the one thing we're still missing is a
front-end UI for the user to actually
interact with a bot in a web application
setting for that we're going to use
angular and this awesome free theme
called nebula not only does nebula look
awesome but it also has a full chat UI
module that we can use to build our chat
bot very quickly we can install it
easily in an existing angular app by
simply running ng add nebula theme that
will install everything automatically in
your project and then if you go in the
app module you can see I'm in poor
in the NB chat UI a module as well as
the spinner module and the only other
angular feature that we need to add here
is the HTTP client module and you'll
find that under the angular common
namespace from there I'm generating a
component called chat bot that will just
encapsulate all of our logic and then
we'll go ahead and declare our chat bot
in the app component now I first want to
go through the code in the template
because nebula is going to take care of
all the heavy lifting here first we'll
declare the NB chat component which is
basically just a wrapper to hold the
messages and the form in order to
display a list of messages from both the
bot and the user will set up the NB chat
message component and then we'll loop
over it using ng for now each message
can be customized with a variety of
input parameters I recommend checking
out the nebula Docs for all the options
but will definitely want to pass any
message text and then we'll determine
whether or not it's a reply to the bot
and we can also pass in a date and a
user avatar image and then also in the
full source code you'll notice I've
added a second message that simply shows
a loading spinner when the bot is
responding and that can be accomplished
easily because nebula ships with a
spinner directive then the last thing
we'll add is the NB chat form which has
its own send event which will be fired
if the user clicks the send button or if
they hit the enter key now moving over
to the component type script the only
thing we really need is angular's HTTP
client and it's used to make requests to
the dialogue flow gateway function that
we defined earlier now moving into the
actual component class we'll set up an
empty array of messages the initial
loading state will be set to false and
then we'll set up a session ID by just
generating a random string you could use
a user ID here or something a little
more sophisticated but this will work
for now now when pushing messages to the
array we have a slightly different set
of data for the bot versus a user when
it's a user generated message the most
important thing is that we set the reply
property to true and nebula will handle
all the styling to display the message
on the right side and then we'll set a
similar method for a bot message with
the only difference being that the
avatar property is defined when the user
first lands on the app we'll go ahead
and add a bot message so they know that
the bot is present and ready to help out
but dialogue flow doesn't really need to
kick in until the user actually sends a
message so when they do send a message
we'll go ahead and add that message to
the chat and then we'll set the loading
state
- true then we can make an HTTP POST
request in angular by calling an HTTP
POST and then we'll set the generic type
to any and pass it our dialogue flow URL
then the second argument is an object
for the request body the cloud function
will be looking for a session ID and
then also a query input object and that
query input object will contain the text
that the user has typed into our chat
forum from there we can actually make
the request by calling SUBSCRIBE
response we get back will contain the
fulfillment text which is the next
message that the bot is saying to the
user and then we'll also set the loading
state to false and that's all there is
to it
when you combine angular with the
nebular theme building a chat UI is
extremely simple I think we've covered
just about enough code for one day so
I'm gonna go ahead and wrap things up
there if this video helped you please
like and subscribe and consider becoming
a pro member at fire ship IO to get
access to even more content thanks for
watching and I will talk to you soon
[Music]